I mean,
you don't play MMA,
you know,
it's your life.
It's interesting too that Ali,
you know,
I always liked to watch that fight with um,
Jerry quarry because it was after three years off.
Yeah,
man.
And you see his body looks different.
Yeah.
It just looks softer.
And if you see Ali versus like Cleveland Williams,
and then you see Ali three years later,
after all that time off,
he just doesn't look the same.
He was never really the same.
He wasn't.
When you think about why he did it,
imagine having the constitution to give away the prime of your fight in Korea
did not do that.
It's very special as they wanted them to fight in the Vietnam War.
It's like,
this is a bullshit bullshit.
None of them ever call it.
He said,
none of them ever called me the n word.
You know what I mean?
And I'm not going over there to do that.
They took three as prime,
yet,
you know,
you've got that window as a fighter man.
It's like four to six years and he and half of it was taken.
It's kind of amazing too that they did that and then they gave it back to him.
They let him fight again.
W I don't know.
What was the circumstances?
Like how did they reinstate his boxing?
I actually don't remember.
I don't know either.
But I remember when he fought Frazier,
I was like,
man,
I would've loved to see this fight three years ago.
Yeah,
man.
Cause he's just was a different guy by then,
was way too flat footed.
It just was a different guy.
Yeah.
I like,
well the Joe because Joe,
Joe and I really hated each other for real.
For Real.
Yeah.
Cause he was,
you know,
I leave with saying horrible,
horrible shit show.
He's trying to fuck with his head and that's how I do it.
He was the original shit.
Talk them.
And Man,
when you think about it,
it's like you see Conor and you're like that sadly.
Oh yeah.
You know what I mean?
For sure.
You know a lot of it like ric flair.
It's like I lay in red flag,
you know?
Yeah.
This is a little bit of both of them.
They're too,
well,
you remember when Henry Cooper knocked down Ali?
That was like the biggest thing in the UK.
I heard him bad and then and uh,
Angelo Dundee cut the gloves.
Yeah.
I mean if it wasn't for that move,
Ali could have lost by stoppage and absolutely.
Very easily.
Absolutely.
I'll fucking craft graphite right on the fucking button and sat down.
He was on Queer Street.
Oh,
100%.
Yeah.
He had a house on Queer Street.
He was picking up the mail.
Here it is right here.
Boom.
Oops.
That again.
Punch that again.
I mean that is a fucking picture.
Perfect lefthand.
I mean,
look at him right on the button.
He is staggering back to his corner.
And it happened luckily for him at the very end of the round.
And I leave back then.
Right.
This was Cassius clay,
correct.
So this is before he fought.
What's it before he fought Sonny Liston?
I want to say it was.
It was,
yeah.
Ooh Man.
Who knows.
They cheated him know.
Yeah,
they did.
They cheated him.
It's different world.
Oh,
we gotta change gloves.
They give him a long ass time.
Oh,
we've got an undo.
These laces.
Cut this.
Cut this tape.
Brilliant though.
Yeah.
Wow.
Hey Angelo.
Dundee.
He wasn't a newcomer.
No,
it was not.
He knew what the fuck he was doing.
He was great man.
Yeah.
My favorite stoppage of all Ali's fights is Cleveland.
Big Cat Williams because he hit him with these just welterweight combinations.
Is anything being he did it pop up,
pop up?
Yeah.
I mean he was throwing it really.
I never saw anyone throw combinations heavyweight like that before.
Like Ray Robinson and the fluidity to fight up.
This was a,
it was one of my all time favorite cause Williams was a scary fucking dude too.
He was a big puncher and Ali was just light on his feet.
No one does that anymore.
Yeah.
And William just kept pressing forward,
pressing forward.
We'll leave.
Williams was a big puncher,
man.
He could crack.
He just couldn't find Ali and Ali was so loose in front of them.
We look at that.
[inaudible] had beautiful,
he's a shelf and on boom,
check,
left hook,
move around.
And then once,
once he started tuning them up,
the jab to the body and then back up top is beautiful man.
Oh Man.
Yeah,
this is art.
This is art,
right?
It's hard because there was never a heavyweight that moved like this.
People have to realize this just didn't exist,
man.
And rarely does exist.
The only guy who moves even remotely like this today is Tyson fury.
Tyson fury can move.
He can,
you motherfucker can't dance.
he dances and he's six foot.
What?
Nine or eight or something should say,
I think he's huge.
He gets clipped a little too much for me and he definitely gets tagged.
Yeah,
he got,
he got tagged by God.
Steve Cunningham from Philly and dropped.
That's the cruiserweight cause even crate,
I'm like always chin might not be all there.
Well you know what?
Cunningham's a shorter guy and sometimes for those really tall fighters it's
very difficult to punch down.
That's how Mike was getting over because he was in the chest and he was real.
I mean that head movement and the,
and the,
and the peekaboo that,
you know,
the custom model developed,
pulled up,
put the end of that fight up so I could see the,
the,
the combinations that led to the stoppage.
See one once he had Williamson trouble go big screen.
I mean even their BombBomb.
Bombbomb.
Yeah.
Like once Williamson's face had been jabbed off and Joe,
the craziest thing,
a beautiful,
the craziest thing about him is everyone historically it has to sit down on
their punches to get leverage on them.
And he did it.
He's dancing and yeah,
I'm on my BombBomb and well he wasn't trying to knock you out with every punch.
He was just cracking you pat,
Pat,
pat,
and where you're getting peppered,
that's fucking tough to deal with Ralph.
The deal,
it's frustrating because you're in your head.
You're like,
if I touched this motherfucker,
I'm gonna hurt them,
but you can't touch him and you just keep getting peppered.
Actually your legs start wobbling a little bit of fight.
Willie pep.
Yeah.
You know,
he was like,
he had the,
you know,
the foot work of Willie Pepin and a heavyweight I'm fucking heard of.
That's another guy that people forgot about.
Willie pep was one of the rare guys that one around without throwing.
Throwing a punch.
Yes.
What the fuck,
man.
Unbelievable.
And a Daigo.
Yes,
indeed.
We had a lot of good ones back in the day.
Maybe not so much now Joseph.
Well,
we had a run.
We had lamato.
We Graziano well,
the community got established.
That's the problem.
People started doing well.
Exactly.
It gets off to exactly,
exactly.
The last guy we had was our total Gadi really rapping.
Yeah.
To really rapping,
you know?
Yeah.
It's,
it's,
that's how it goes though,
right?
The early immigrants,
the ones that get shit on,
they're the ones who come up strong.
They're tough fighters.
And then,
you know,
now it's Cubans and Russians and cause because you come from that rock,
that rush and amateur program,
like there's no fucking joke.